hey what's going on it's Bill Burr it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday uh May 22nd 2023 what's going on
and how are you
and how are you doing and how are you
feeling
and what do you think about your
candidates chances for the 2024 election
oh Jesus can you believe it's [__]
already going around again didn't we
just [__] do this
um oh my God people are [__]
gonna get all ramped up for that
can both sides agree that the last time
we had we did this it was the two worst
[__] choices ever
going Head to Head
my God
okay what do you like reality show or
dementia
um anything's better than reality show
um
anyway yeah the amount of stupidity on
the internet somebody try to say there
were no Wars when Trump was president
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like if a war just keeps going if
it just at what point does it just not
it's not even a war anymore
it's not even well yeah the [__]
we're bankrupt because Joe Biden's been
president for four years has nothing to
do with the Federal Reserve
anyway I say this all the time but
nobody gives a [__] let's plow ahead
here
um how about your Los Angeles Lakers and
your Boston Celtics once again on a
collision course to meet
in the NBA Finals all right
um
yeah they're both getting their [__]
asses kicked
by better teams better organizations
that's basically what is happening and
you know what's funny
is it's great to see the Denver Nuggets
are going to make the NBA Finals right
and the Miami Heat are going to go back
and my buddy goes like he goes to finals
is going to be the [__] nuggets and
the Heats who the [__] gonna watch
that it's like why wouldn't you watch it
they're obviously the two best teams
because you know what it is the NBA sold
their soul to the [__] super team so
now like people literally have it in
their head that only certain franchises
deserve to go there
um as much as I hate watching the
Celtics get stomped
you know
I was [__] nervous about that Miami
Heat team but it's it's I I'll take that
to watch the Lakers get stomped with yet
again
Superstar players from other people's
teams you know I just don't [__]
uh that that [__] franchise just
represents
you know not all the way back not the
way back I give it up to him 100 right
through [__] Magic Johnson and all
it's amazing and I also give it up to
them that they know how to play the free
agency game but this [__] [__] of
like you know
it's it's business location location all
these guys want to go out to Hollywood
and Bang movie stars so they're going to
go to your [__] team and uh
I don't know it's like trying to keep up
with the rich kid down the street and
his dad keeps buying him a new [__]
Ferrari
um
I don't I I don't know you always
another [__] thing that let's just be
I'm gonna be a little grumpy old man
here
if I see another [__] nobody
like who the [__] is this guy what have
you ever done with your [__] life
you know making some [__] video
giving out life advice
like who are you okay now now film it in
black and white and then put like I'm
saying it you know important [__] music
I think if you're giving out really good
life advice you don't you don't have to
hire a musician or you don't have to go
buy music
you know you don't have to score your
opinion
with some John Williams music could you
just say something that really made
sense
I saw this guy the other day all right
I'm gave you some most important life
advice
you're ever going to hear in your life
don't do dumb [__]
[Music]
that's all the guy had don't do dumb
[__] and it's in black and white and all
these choppy [__] edits and they're
playing this [__] music underneath
that you're like oh wow man
oh I was gonna go out today and do dumb
[__]
then they then then they hide I know it
sounds simple really sit there and think
about it don't do
dumb [__] oh thank you thank you what
else have you figured out
let me give you guys some great advice
all right
here's the deal don't take your tongue
and stick it in a well socket
all right think about that
put some ominous music underneath that
I'm gonna give you guys some life advice
all right
this may sound simple but this is one of
the most important pieces of advice
you're ever going to get
don't take your dick out at work
and then I just need
I just need someone who's listening to
me to act like they're blown away but
that's power ful
[Laughter]
then I saw this other podcast
where these two people are are talking
about Kobe Bryant as if there's a bunch
of people out there
claiming he wasn't a great basketball
player
you know they paid million people
millions of dollars to go all around the
world
to try and find
the top talent in the world
to try and stop Kobe Bryant
yet the man still scores
81 points
in an NBA basketball game it's like yeah
yeah
we were all aware of that
you've introduced no new information
[Laughter]
that's whatever that's the part of
Instagram I'm on
you know
I [__] for some reason every day
somebody has to tell me I and my feed is
somebody telling me Lebron is the
greatest basketball player in the world
ever or he isn't
or Michael Jordan is or he isn't
I get those I get old truck videos
and booty models
I'm sorry women working out
I'm [__] working out
um
it is funny how like everybody has to
dress like a [__] a hori Power Ranger
now when they work out it seems
I do feel bad for young people now where
everything is an outfit you can't just
get on a bicycle you know back in the
day you just got on your bike and you
rode it
like what is your bike riding outfit um
whatever I put on this morning
now if you actually ride a bicycle down
the street wearing just regular street
clothes people think you're a convicted
drunk driver
that's what I always think if I see a
guy in jeans and a t-shirt just riding a
bicycle down the street
you know
um that's what I think
he's divorced convicted drunk driver
um
I know he's got the shakes so he won't
let him drive a car I don't [__] know
right
but if I see somebody
you know
dressed up like they're in the Tour de
France I just got all that guys
that guy's a douche
why do they wear those stupid [__]
outfits
when they're riding their bicycles I
just don't understand like
you're not in a time trial like why do
you waste all that [__] money then my
favorite thing ever is you get those
stupid shoes
and then you lock your feet into the
[__] petals
[Music]
you know what so you can get that extra
Edge when you're driving down [__]
Main Street
um
yeah I don't you know
the overhead just the [__] overhead
of being a person that we you know
smartphones laptops and then these
[__] outfits for everything that you
do
you know when I was growing up people
just dressed like Malcolm Young and they
did whatever they were doing
I'm not saying it was better I'm just
saying it was cheaper
I'm sure we weren't riding bicycles as
fast
um
I don't ever remember my looser clothing
getting caught in like the [__]
Nautilus equipment maybe that's what
happened
you know if you work in a factory you
know they always made you if you had a
ponytail you put your [__] hair up
you know loose clothing because you get
dragged into the machine
um
whatever I'm making fun of it as I look
at these [__] women like wearing
these skin tight [__] clothes
so they didn't dress well you know maybe
that's what it stopped I mean I think
actually
when I think about it kind of started in
my generation the spandex [__] was was
the 80s
I mean I've ever seen In Living Color
opened up for the Rolling Stones in the
Steel Wheels tour and their lead singer
was dressed like he was going to go
spear fishing and nobody questioned it
it was like bright yellow
he had everything but like flippers and
a snorkel on
and I remember I worked in a warehouse
and there was this guy I worked the uh I
worked the second shift
it was like [__]
2 to 11 or 3 to midnight I forget what
it was and that was all drug addicts and
divorcees I do remember that and War
veterans
and then [__] like me
um
yeah like my manager at night
was in was fought in the Vietnam War and
he was was right on the DMZ and he had
one of those anti-aircraft guns you know
that almost go like the Rock'em sock'em
robots and he had it pointed
horizontally at the tree line
that was his job
and to this day I have never met a
person
that could drink at the pace
that that guy drank
and he would drink beer too he wasn't
even a hard stuff guy he would drink
beer
and you would go out with that guy
and he would hand you one and you'd get
about a third of the way down and you'd
have hand you the second one next you
know you'd be like holding like a six
pack of Bud bottles and you'd be going
Frank dude you got it you gotta [__]
gotta slow down here
and he would just laugh he'd be smoking
these [__] cigarettes non-stop
there's no [__] way that guy's still
alive
no [__] way
um
so rest in peace to him
but anyways there was somebody that
worked
um
that worked on that shift and he would
show up every day
with spandex shorts on
and like no no other like running shorts
over them just like his junk
shape with shape shape what junk
shapewear is what he went remember like
that [__] tour Guns and Roses did an
Axel Rose Road the [__] white uh bike
shorts the whole time
nobody questioned it
you know looking like a superhero at the
end of the day like he took off this
[__] Spider-Man shirt
I don't know what I'm talking about all
I know is I'm excited that uh the Denver
Nuggets are beating the [__] [__] out
of the uh Los Angeles Lakers
um
but um
I'm not excited watching my Celtics so
Jesus Christ
I miss game one my buddy said they
scored like 41 points that he did 41
points in the third quarter and we
called No timeouts
I think that's our strategy I think
we're saving them up
for game four and we're gonna start
using those
and we're going to turn this whole
goddamn series around
um
anyway oh yeah there's my friends
complaining the Celtics have two Pippins
and no Jordans
I mean last I checked Scottie Pippen had
[__]
what do you have six yeah
six rings
symmetrical part
uh nobody has a Jordan on that team
right now
Jordan it's Jordan right that's it
it's not gonna be another one of those
it's not gonna be another Kobe I don't
think it's gonna be another LeBron did
they just you know just enjoy them
stop [__] comparing him dude [__]
naked guys better than Metallica man
you're [__] heavier I like the
subject man dude Biggie Smalls he's
better than Tupac kids [__] just
enjoy them
young talented [__]
[Laughter]
the number one people who argue about
whether LeBron is better than Michael
Jordan probably can't hit a layup
I would guess
you know what I mean although I've
trashed I've trashed
I've trashed plenty of [__] athletes
haven't I
maybe that's a part of it I don't
[__] know it's funny how I keep
making these statements and then it just
goes back to either me or my generation
oh yeah we kind of did [__] like that
actually my generation
I think is when dressing like you were
in the Tour de France started
but like everybody didn't do it
you know
we've got these these [__]
you know that it Wicks away the sweat
off of your body
uh Bill what are you bitching about
improvements I don't know maybe
I have no idea so anyway I've been away
for the last uh four days
with my lovely wife uh we came up here a
little bit early we uh in wine country
we went to a wedding a very close
friends and a beautiful wedding
quick weddings succinct wedding
that's like the new thing man they when
I was a kid of the goddamn [__]
wedding ugh
you'd go there if it was a Catholic
medic that wedding they'd have a whole
[__] Mass
when first time I went to a wedding and
they had they had a mass before they got
married oh God I was [__] livid
standing in the back like this means I
don't have to go again on Sunday right
this counts
this is a friendly
they had a whole [__] mass and by the
end of it I hated the couple
I was like why would you do this to
people there was no [__] air
conditioning when there's old ass
goddamn
Church oh
you know but I will say in Massachusetts
the greatest thing about the weddings in
Massachusetts is the open bar
everyone you went to [__] open bar
people getting blitzed falling down
I mean it was just a [__] show
looking like a [__]
prom for old people
um
anyway so we've been up here in wine
country and uh
you know a couple bunnies of mine up
here they're both married too they
brought their wives up there was a cigar
bar the ladies went to go down and go
you know drink the wine
do the wine tasting as they call it
does anybody dance around their
alcoholism more than a Wine Drinker
you know what I mean
they're sort of like they're like the
cigar smokers
of drinkers where cigar smokers always
like yeah but I'm not inhaling
I'm not inhaling it's not bad you know
like just so-and-so smoke like six
cigars A Day his whole [__] life you
know
people who drink wine are the same way
they're so busy talking about
the body of the wine the smell the
different you know
whatever the [__] it is
California has more of a Jammy wine
because it's hot or something so you get
that Jammy Flavor now some people like
it other people don't if you want the
drier ones you got to go
it's like yeah if I could intervene you
guys are just getting wasted all right
[Laughter]
is really
I mean I understand I understand I
enjoyed wine back when I drank but I
will tell you this
I will I'll give you guys some life's
advice okay
and this may sound simple
all right there is no hangover worse
than a red wine hangover
there's no advice there but if you put
music underneath it it'll sound [__]
like I said something I just remember
doing I remember that drinking red wine
in the next day
waking up like
like my head was in a fight I don't know
what it was
beer was one thing that's one great
thing about not drinking
you know
it's not how you feel physically it's
it's really just not having to apologize
or be embarrassed to be oh God
oh Jesus I take my shirt off
oh that other people are taking this
[__] you know he tried to [__]
justify it the next day other people
were drinking too maybe they don't
remember
then it's 11 30 in the morning you just
you still haven't gotten a text message
then you start putting feelers out like
hey man
pretty banged up I don't even remember
like past like 10 o'clock you always do
that you give yourself a two hour
cushion before whatever [__] thing
you did
where did we go after
where did we go out after that second
bar I don't I don't even remember yeah
you do
yeah you do
you 100 remember what you did or what
you said and now what you're doing is
you're trying to see if the person you
did it to remembers
that wasn't even me I don't
I don't even know
um
so anyway
um coming back today and we were up here
in uh
Paso Robles
uh
beautiful part of California
you know most people around the country
[__] on California
uh because they're not happy with their
own lives
and um and that's what you do oh I live
over here you live over there your place
sucks my place is better
um the wine country out here is [__]
amazing it really is amazing I can't
believe I never do this this place is
like a you know a couple two three hour
drive
up from Los Angeles
I was saying to my wife like why don't
we do this more oh that's right we have
kids
[Laughter]
but I think if they get just a little
bit older we'll be able to come up here
and they won't be bored shitless
and um
I just like coming up here and getting
away from the traffic
although they were saying that they've
been last couple years is kind of
blowing up up here
that always happens you know can a
sleepy town just stay a sleepy town
um
that's why we saw Doug Stanhope figured
it out
Doug Stanhope figured it out like I
don't know how many years ago has he
been out
living in the middle of nowhere
for like 20 years the piece of that must
be amazing
and then to be like also pick a place
that then eventually doesn't get like
over developed
you have to go wait you have to like go
three layers in to small town
you know what I mean like take all these
all these [__] people are moving to
Nashville Tennessee so you know what's
going to happen eventually people are
like I can't [__] deal with this
they're gonna go to Knoxville they're
gonna go to Chattanooga or they're going
to go to [__] Memphis but eventually
one of those places all of those places
are going to fill up
so you got you got to find that place
that's like gonna be three generations
away from blowing up
if you actually want peace and quiet and
not have traffic
but then the problem is
is you got to hear the n-word
[Laughter]
there's always a price to pay
maybe not that but you're just they're
going to be like
you know middle and nowhere people
you'd think the internet
the internet would like would I maybe
that's helping things a little bit
because that was the only thing you live
in the middle of nowhere and then the
world view is middle of nowhere
so you got to deal with that chicken
little [__] sky is falling
[__]
um
oh God I had this [__] creepy guy
come up to me the other day I was
working on something
and he was like uh
he's like hey man he goes he had a shady
Vibe he was you're all right I like you
you not one of those psycho lefties
so I looked at him I go yeah I'm also
not one of those psycho righties
and he goes yeah yeah that's it you know
everybody just getting along whatever
happened to that
it's like uh when was that
was there a time when everyone was
getting along
well he's [__] politically active
[__] idiots on both sides
[__] drive me up the wall all right
um energy is a little low people I mean
I'm not not gonna lie to you all right
the wedding was last night
you know the deal
it just [__]
you know you get to be my age
it just takes a lot out of you you know
you find yourself more and more sitting
down
hey how you doing you know you know what
was cool was
um
oh I'm sorry the wedding was two nights
ago
um yesterday they had like a brunch
afterward
and uh me and Neil were hanging out they
had the brunch down by the pool
and the uh the grooves
brother's daughter who is nine years old
was sort of hanging out near us talking
to us and she was absolutely hilarious
and uh it was really cool as a parent
being oh my God that's what a
nine-year-old girl is like that's going
to be awesome when my daughter gets to
be nine because I'm already kind of
freaking out because my daughter's
already six and you're like oh my God
it's going by so fast
you know
they said there's that dread you have
as a parent I think where you just start
going what is the age where my kid's
gonna start hating me
you know because obviously I started
super late
and um
there's very like there's I there's a
few like they're actually friends of
mine like their kids don't hate them and
they're in their teen teenage years
and they're not being like [__]
lunatics and that type of stuff but like
pretty much when I go on the road
that's like the number one thing that
people tell me
oh I'm so happy you have kids hey enjoy
them while they're young before they get
older and turn into [__] [__]
like people say that about their own
kids I'm like Jesus
before they turn into [__] [__]
um you saying about that about your own
kid
um
I don't know
hopefully I'm old enough and wise enough
to not take any of that [__] personally
probably wouldn't have been as good at
it
10 years ago forget about 20 years ago
so we'll see but as of right now
everything's been going good moving
right along and uh it's time for the
reads but for some reason they're not
loading
why aren't the Reeds the advertising
reads load oh here we go loading loading
loading
the set ads happens to be all [__]
time
like it just it stops refreshing right
like oh have I really not gotten a
[__] email since May 14th
all right I gotta stop this thing and
figure this [__] up
the road here if you hear a little road
s the lovely Mia
oh hello you know what's a pro traveling
trip
Pro traveling trip that I always forget
tip what did I say a pro traveling trip
is what you said oh you meant Pro
traveling tip that's what I meant
is uh
before you leave is to pack a roll
of a four-ply toilet paper like the
toilet paper that you use in your house
because I don't care how nice
a hotel you stay at they all got that
one ply see-through [__] listen they got
a lot of overhead so something has a
good sacrifice and unfortunately for you
it's your [__] that's not sad
there's two days in a four-star hotel
if you don't bring four ply toilet paper
your [__] is going to feel like it
fell off a skateboard yeah you really
wanted to you wanted to go to the
drugstore you're like I want to go and
pick up some toilet paper I've been on
the road long enough
are you just is that gonna be a thing do
you think that you travel with
or maybe it's like oh in your Rider from
now on it's one of those things whatever
Hotel he's in it's one of those things
since I've been doing the road since the
90s I say to myself you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna treat myself in my
[__] when I'm on the road and I never
do it and I always come in there and you
try to wad it up as much as you can to
try to make a one-ply a two-ply and it
is it you know what I mean it just isn't
you know people you can do a makeover on
they can go to the gym they can do all
this stuff they can put makeup on it but
one ply is one ply look at that some
dust devils
they're out here in Bakersfield
that's right and this is just oh no
there's a track oh tractor sorry it's a
tractor pulling well you couldn't see it
look how beautiful this all is the
scenery that we're driving past is
absolutely gorgeous and if this was a
video podcast we could show it to you
but it is it isn't it
it's not a vlog but uh no this is the
part of California the wine country in
between uh San Francisco and Los Angeles
that nobody talks about right all they
talk about a bunch of libtards in
Hollywood and then uh you know Harvey
Milk up in San Francisco they think that
that's Jesus
I know
scariest sound ever in the back of a fan
okay no no this is the scariest sound
when you started okay when you start to
sleep you just hear
[Music]
[Applause]
that's that's the scare like he's on the
shoulder
The Vineyards
um
[Music]
honey a gym all right well with that we
gotta do some reads here for the week
um a little bit of advertising here
uh is this still [__] recording this
it is still recording okay oh you know
what I didn't I didn't I was supposed to
do at the top of the podcast but I
didn't have the information yet is oh oh
[__] uh oh Billy Euro Step
hero step yeah Euro Step that's a new
thing in basketball okay it used to be
called traveling but over in Europe they
invented a new way to travel and you
know we always like low-key think the
Europeans do stuff a little bit better
you know it makes you feel clever
actually I would argue
that the original Euro Step was created
by the original skateboarders back in
the 1970s Generation X that was the
precursor to the Euro Step and that
would be back when you know we had the
original skateboards that were they
basically
Jesus Christ didn't James Dean die up
here
um
the original skateboards were like so
thin like even as a kid like basically
the arch of your foot was on the board
and you had your heels and you you know
for the ball of your [__] all the way
up to your toes was hanging off so you'd
get the wobbles really quick first thing
you did was you found the wobbles the
wobbles you started yeah like a tank
slap as they say in motorcycle but this
is just with your [__] ankles so
you'd be going down the hill and you
didn't realize with the technology back
then all it took was one little Pebble
one little stick just the idea a leaf
would just stop your [__] skateboard
you're probably going like 30 miles an
hour you didn't know to crouch down we
were like the goaltenders back then this
is pretty Patrick nobody went down to
the butterfly even on skateboards and
you would just be standing straight up
and down like [__] Jerry Chavis and
uh
you think in your head the first first
time you just be like oh I'll just step
off this thing and I'll be fine and you
would just you do this giant step and
you'd go flying but you lost interest
halfway through yeah I mean can we just
get back to what a Euro stepper is
the Euro Step it's like this big step
where you don't dribble oh but and so
they don't call it they don't call it
it's called a Euro Step what
who is calling it that well listen some
of the best players are from Europe and
they wanted to make them feel welcome so
we'll it's like we'll allow that I think
you have to be European or Lebron James
to get away with it though all right I
got European dates coming up all right
they're on sale baby September 4th I'm
gonna be in Prague Czech Republic at the
Prague Congress Center and I'll tell you
right now nothing says stand-up comedy
like the Prague Congress Center I think
I'm going to be at a podium
talking about the the threat of Russia
coming back to Eastern Europe
yeah um
they I've only been there for about 36
hours and I had a great time before all
right
September 6th
Berlin Germany at the Mercedes-Benz
Arena huh you like that oh freckles
freckles goes back to the motherland and
those people show up that's right
um
September 7th there is going to be an
audience full of men that look just like
the only Boris Becker shows up
um September 7th I'll go Stockholm
Sweden oh our old stomping ground okay
one of the first times that bill and I
traveled internationally together when
we're still dating which I am not
including New Hampshire go ahead no we
don't include our first New Hampshire or
our first trip together to New Hampshire
to a lake in New Hampshire hey I was
struggling back then that was that was
some big money moves when I was on my
futon we're in the captain's Lodge I I
sprung for the captain's Lodge
worked it out it was a fun weekend but
it was fun but Stockholm was one of the
first cities internationally that bill
and I traveled together and I I had was
working at MTV I had left MTV and I
always say that if I was still working
that job I would not have been able to
travel with you as much as we did like
we literally went all around the world
together before we were even engaged
we did yeah yeah we did all those cities
together yeah when we flew around the
world when I did that Asia trip yep um
so anyway Stockholm Sweden September 7th
I'll be at the avisai arena
uh September 8th oh my God these guys is
one of the best overseas comedy cities
I've ever been to where Budapest Hungary
I'm so jealous I'm not gonna be able to
go on any of these
gonna be awesome well yeah send me lots
of pictures I'm at The Budapest Congress
Center this is like the funny bone this
is their funny bones I'm working all of
them yeah yeah I did last time I did
Budapest I had a show I was like I
should have shot that and put it out as
a special they got everything and then
uh September 11th never forget
uh I'll be in Athens Greece
at the Odeon of Hercules that is so
Heroes Atticus I'm playing a ruin
ruin okay and the rest of it's gonna
fall down after my [__] jokes all right
so there you go
one more time September 4th in Prague
September 6th Berlin Germany September
7th Stockholm Sweden September 8th
Budapest hungry oh Jesus
[__] hitting the [__] whoopty
dudes here September 11th in Athens
Greece and uh if you think I'm not
bringing
the original Greek Freak Paul Versi on
that trip you got another thing coming
and prague's only Bianca Christoval is
going to be on that trip it's gonna be
sick all right and with that let's do uh
let's do the reads for the week Nia
okay the Reeds oh no wait I gotta do the
uh the libraries hang on a second I
already did the new dates okay the
pre-sale for all of that's gonna be
sorry it's gonna be
Wednesday May 17th 10 a.m local
oh wait this is something else that's
last week is that last week yeah ignore
what I just said
um what the [__] the advertising
create emails I don't think I have any
AD reads uh geez I'm pissing them all
off then here all right we're gonna go
right to the uh
we're gonna go right to the content here
Nia you still here with me you'll be
back you're back on your phone I know
it works okay check out for a second
okay all right
Billy Joel joke
hello my Ginger Guru Billy bunghole
long time first time in the May 16th
podcast as you promoted your new dates
uh you got into a riff of Allentown
Pennsylvania in an attempt at levity
suggested the town sounded like a Billy
Joel
should sounded like Billy Joel should
write a song about it thing is he did
record a song called Allentown now that
you said that I remember that
something something in Allentown isn't
that him that's not that's not didn't
that sound like a hit uh it's the lead
it's the lead track on Joel's 1982 album
The nylon Curt it's a good name for an
album accompanied by a conceptional
conceptual music video upon its release
and especially in subsequent years
Allentown emerged as an Anthem of blue
collar America representing both the
aspiration and frustrations of America's
working class in the late 20th century
how about that anyway the red-headed
brain is a funny thing right thanks for
all the laughs and go [__] yourself
furzie too that's hilarious now that's
just more me being old going like hey
Billy Joe should write a song about this
it's like he did
that's the California Aqueduct you keep
missing it
that's all that
you place me like several miles back I
keep waiting for you to be impressed did
I not say to you as in Chinatown
remember that whole combo and you were
like yeah and then we talked from there
I guess so I think I have fonder
memories with that
all right oh Jesus somebody's gonna take
me to task about the Federal Reserve
so of what oh yes that truck stop no
oh yeah right now we're on the five
just entering the Hills
before we come to the uh the back of the
San Gabriel's and go through New Hall
Pass there Nia
and then we're back into the LA Basin
also known as the valley back home baby
um all right well I'm gonna continue
reading here all right
all right the federal is fed Reserve
hey Billy effing [__] face Jesus don't
you love the love I get from my
listeners
let me explain you reasons the FED is
still here
well I keep saying instead of blaming uh
blue ties and red ties why doesn't the
president just send half a platoon
over to those habit Dash [__] and just
say this [__] is over right
he said here's the reason the FED is
still here one we can't march in there
because it's a separate country
yeah well since when has that stopped us
don't we just start a uh a coalition of
the willing
yeah it's owned by Britain
I thought we'd freed ourselves from
those [__] the District of Columbia is
a fortress
that's why it's not a state
ostensibly did I say that right an act
of War needs to be approved first they
are just here to collect our money
haven't you ever wondered why we have a
state that isn't a state well what they
what I was told
in my um
in my my history class is they the
reason why the District of Columbia was
called a district and was not put in any
state is because they didn't want to get
any of the other states get jealous
going well how come the capital of the
country is there
and nowhere else that's what I was told
you're just going to be on the other
side of the van eating snacks near
well I don't know what to contribute to
that one
well listen I remember back before we
got to that mess in the Middle East when
we said we were going to go into Iraq
nobody came along with us
meaning NATO and so then we just created
our own board
so this is not new territory for us
all right I'm not a revolutionary I'm
just [__] bringing up you know I'm
just saying you got well I don't
understand why [__] Men's Warehouse
has a Stranglehold on this [__]
country and we're acting like we don't
have nerds with drones that could
[__] you know turn a lot of things
around for people
um anyway
all right are we going over the whoopty
deuce again
Pepsi here
I refuse really categorically refused to
drink Pepsi
you can take Pepsi you can take your
Gray Goose Gray Goose too that that's
all for weak people Gray Goose is for
weak people let me tell you if you want
somebody solid they gotta drink
something like Belvedere Vodka wow okay
what about kind of one uh Kettle one's
old school I'll go with that I don't
have to hear their world view first
Kettle One
Gray Goose is for [__] people today I
just I don't wanna I wanna drink alcohol
but not drink alcohol it's like it's
smooth enough and then they [__] they
put it in with Kool-Aid I used to it's a
good mixer I think that's why they
always bring Goose at the club with the
mixers because it just mixes it the
goose you went around the block a few
times huh blame it on the goose blame it
on the goose how's it feeling loose
shout out to Jamie Foxx all right I like
the uh Jamie Foxx yes
get well soon I keep hearing good things
about it though which makes me uh very
happy absolutely arguably the most
talented guy
since Eddie Murphy maybe ridiculously
um all right so
plowing ahead here what the [__] was I
talking about before I got up did I tell
you that I use flower head when I did
that Michelin gig in Miami you did it
works great right yeah you're addressing
that whatever just happened didn't go
the way you planned yeah so can we just
should we just plow ahead and I just was
going Fly Away
crowd came with you right they came with
me well that's how most people said on
stage I was like that's my husband's set
I totally saw that from him yeah I'm not
good at stopping and going back and
getting it right
I'm good
yeah and then when my sins from the past
catch up with me I respond with anger
um
I was gonna say that sounded pretty much
like Jesus
could count the wrinkles on that
Trucker's face
real-time Adventure that people are
getting yes it is riding in the back of
a van
past the ponderosi
[Music]
um all right yeah so what else what else
do I think is [__] I think Doritos
are [__]
Doritos
to read I remember a long time Keith
Robinson told me all of them oh
they just never beat Fritos Fritos are
better well whoa this is what I this is
my feeling okay long time ago wow a wise
mean old man named Keith Robinson
he told me there's two kinds of black
people he goes this earth-winded fire
black people and then this hip-hop black
people saying there was a Line in the
Sand with the generations yes that it
they went in different directions
and I would say in white people world oh
no
this this Fritos white people and then
there's Doritos and much like hip-hop
Doritos laid waste
to the uh the Fritos the Frito world
that I lived in bill can I have the
answer to you when it comes to Fritos I
know how much you love Fritos
the only time anyone eats Fritos it was
chili It's not like a snacking chip you
like it as a snacking chip who does you
but Doritos hands down is is more of the
same but can I tell you something right
now chili the chili Fritos are good
though I'll tell you this right yeah how
much more [__] do you need to put in
your chili before you realize you need
to season it more if I gotta put it like
if I gotta put Fritos in my chili you
you didn't make it right
oh it's just like a little dipping thing
no you think you should just be like
taking Fritos no Frito Fritos are the
Peds of chili
performance enhancing drugs meaning you
shouldn't be in the league but you shall
but you're getting there you know
you're going you know
haven't you in a Frito pie I'll tell you
right now Barry Bonds
pre-1997 did not need to put Fritos in
his chili but because guys like Sosa and
McGuire started putting Fritos in that
chili he then goes all right here's my
chili with Fritos and now somehow he
became the bad guy everything
I'm a limited guy
you're unlimited and your knowledge of
sports
like you're limited this is Nia trying
to save an insult she just threw across
the table thinking I'm pulling out a
reference but everything is like a
sports room it's just kind of wild
tonight
did you hear that did you hear that it's
just it's just kind of wild to me
you know when that was such a passive
aggressive
like sports reference
it'll be like that time McGregor was in
the ninth at the top of the I don't even
know that was going good that was a good
name I was like McGregor
McGregor Owen McGregor who the [__] is
McGregor in sports Colin Colin McGregor
now you got my brain all [__]
confused all right
that's one for the wife sometimes you
just lay it off across the [__] table
all right let's get back to this here
well I got me just get back
you're either
what was wrong with Pringles I'm just an
old guy
they stacked them up neatly like a deck
of cards
yeah who likes Pringles anymore sorry
Pringles but I love Pringles the
flavored ones the flavored ones like the
sour cream and onion ones ugh or the
cheddar cheddar sour cream I don't like
the remix on all of this [__] you like
the plain as [__] I don't like the plain
as [__] free throws plain who likes
playing what should we decide dude Oreos
pretzel that uh M M's all of them within
9 000 ranches [__] flavors the kids
like Flavor huh flavor is good though
who gets plain Pringles you're the only
one espresso flavored Doritos
bar what's that when they give you this
short little thing of Pringles you
demolish those every time I think
demolish is kind of a strong word
I would have gone more with enjoy enjoy
40 in a whack
I know
well I've always maintained that you eat
like a panda eat some of that bok choy
my wife can be a Smacker when she's
really hungry
um
is that what you call it yeah I thought
it was Bad Manners all right I'm kidding
all right food dish for [__] what is
this okay oh now I'm paying attention no
I would say
do tell
all right food dish for [__] uh I was
talking about
somehow I said [__] food I don't even
know why see it's not all sports
references oh sometimes it's about [__]
food yeah and I was saying like what
would that look like oh because they all
like you know those those cooking shows
you know what I mean they always have to
have like the wholesome girl but
underneath she's letting you know that
she's an animal in the wreck oh and who
what what
I work I'm just getting over here okay
um all right food dish for [__] uh so I
was saying what would [__] food look
like uh dear Billy Buffet belly Burr
um on Monday's show you were joking that
there's no dishes for [__]
uh wait hold on oh wait the driver yes
what okay beautiful all right
just got the old ETA there hour and six
minutes all right
um
okay on Monday's show you were joking
that there's no dishes for [__]
spaghetti a la putanesca Loosely
translate to [__] spaghetti really I
mean this guy could be lying I don't
know I'll have to ask Dom lombardozy
uh while the etymology is debated one
possible origin is that this was a dish
served to paste patrons
at the bordellos another possible origin
is that it was a dish created near
closing time at a restaurant where the
chef made a sauce with whatever limited
ingredients he had left even though
putana literally means [__]
uh Bhutan Italians use it for multiple
curse words so putanesca could mean
something along the lines of
whatever [__] was in the cupboard
I feel like I've heard them use that on
The Sopranos all right
well God knows that The Sopranos said it
that that's good enough for me yeah
anyway I prefer the first possible
origin for the dish all the best and go
[__] yourself PS an email on Monday
mention
call signs the one given to me is
puddles but what you land on lakes but
traditionally you only share the origin
of the name after a few adult beverages
oh God I didn't want to know what that
means does he like to get peed on they
call him old puddles
all right his sayings that you get wrong
okay all right everybody if you made the
mistake of this next person it's death
Nell
k-n-e-l-l not death nail
it says Oh Billy
um one saying that I got wrong I like
that this person can admit that they got
it wrong yeah of course after I've been
saying anyways for the last 15 years one
saying that I got wrong until I saw it
written was death now I thought it was
death nail
I wouldn't have corrected you
um I always thought it was the final
nail in the coffin
a death nail yeah well that's what
happens with these sayings where it's
the final nail in the coffin and then
death now becomes death nail he's not
the brightest bulb to come down the pipe
yeah
it's not the brightest bulb on the
Christmas tree or he's not the brightest
Bowl it's not the brightest Bowl period
That's not the brightest bulb yeah any
blue you want to judge it up you sand
the Christmas tree I guess but oh
yeah Auntie Christmas I didn't know that
um but anyways the guy says uh yeah it's
not death nail oh contraire mon frere uh
it's death Nell meaning the ringing of a
belt
marking the death of a person
uh and and when is your next next flips
next Netflix special coming out when I
learned how to talk probably inquiring
minds want to know when you start doing
podcasts from the back of Vance
oh you like that one didn't you you were
really impressed I know it wasn't that
good it was it wasn't that bad
I mean if I edited anything the podcast
that might have gone oh I get it all
right
civil Ware
Mr Bob The Bill Burr
um oh this guy's he said I said
something pretty dumb once my wife
girlfriend at the time and I got out and
I asked her if she needed any silverware
civil war Civil War well he's a civil
guy and several people eat with utensils
uh she made me Google
sorry going over bumps she made me
Google what I said
Google didn't even have a suggestion
I've been there when I'm trying to spell
things like feng shui it's looking at me
like they're like you are so far off
yeah that we got nothing yeah
um yeah it starts coming up like what
language are you trying to speak anyway
this person said I was 26 when I
realized forks and knives were called
silverware
[__] idiot uh I think my New England
accent made the word silverware morph
into silverware hey why don't you
hey what do we animals get some
silverware over here Jesus Christ
have a little Clash
um
silverware
no we can't do that because I remember
when when we started saying you liked it
that you liked it did that remember we
said that yeah this guy said in a
particular thing that we were watching
yes you liked it that you liked it at
that and then we started saying that to
each other you liked it at that and then
one time I took a meeting with an agent
in a critical
part of my career and I was talking
about a movie and I said I liked it I
liked it and I just saw the look on his
face and he was like oh my God this guy
this guy is is I'm not representing him
um anyway uh
the guy says I suppose that I never
really needed to write the word so it
never came up I also Justified it in my
head as you be civilized to use forks
and knives yeah unlike The Barbarians
that would use their hands contacts like
ancient cavemen
uh not looking down on anybody huh no
offense hashtag I also know
um I noted
I noted above that we got married so
people know you can walk things like
this off she likes to bring it up all
the at all the Gatherings oh my God the
one thing that she's got on here though
and he writes though t-o-u-g-h
yeah uh I don't know he got haha right
come on
I said I liked it
um all right let's let's read the last
one here and then we're going to ramp up
the the the jam in the van man yes
um oh that was a that was a coveted spot
the Monday morning Jam in the van oh jam
in the van was the name of a show I was
doing during uh coven
uh of Santa Monica there all right
advice Bill oh good we got the leveling
unit here
uh I'm a 33 year old piece of [__]
millennial
you guys aren't pieces of [__] for some
reason you know what happened social
media came out and then Gen X got old
and then they blamed you for everything
that us and Baby Boomers did we're all
[__] [__]
um
if you haven't read the rest of them
okay all right we'll see that owns a
plumbing company
90 of my work
is for high-end Custom Homes this guy's
crushing it for Boomers
that I feel don't respect or trust me
because of my age granted I was a poor
lazy Millennial that didn't have a real
job until I was 26 when I started
Plumbing well looks like you've been
killing it since then
the guy goes on to say I got my act
together when I turned 30 and within
three years
the age of Christ did he die or get a
hooker at 33. I can't remember
um he was getting hookers way before
that oh yeah you know those construct
you know they work hard they play hard
anyway they wash my feet all right
um I got my act together when I turned
30 got married and now have a nine month
old son congratulations I hope to give
the business too uh I'm always fair and
honest about my pricing I'm not perfect
and when I do [__] up I always fix it
without question and always eat the cost
on anything I miss
dare I say the way you're hyping
yourself you sound like a dream plumber
here uh I've tried to hire multiple
times but hiring older than me I get no
respect and hiring younger than me they
have no respect in general I need a few
employees oh why don't you go to Old zip
recruit it that's right ZipRecruiter or
get a mix get some older guys and some
younger guys and you have to be the
[__] boss that's the thing you have
to like establish at the top like this
is how it is this is how it's going down
you gotta have to have that sense of
like
strength and like being a leader from
the jump are you telling him in a
plumbing sense to clap back no damn it I
always wanted him to boss up boss up I
never get those expressions right but I
didn't I didn't let you finish reading
the things okay well here we go I'm
finishing here uh I need a few few
inflow employees but I can't find the
help I need because they think they can
do what they they want because of my age
and the company not being around for
very long
uh how can I start getting respect by
these guys that have been in the
construction business as long as I've
been alive uh you got to remind them
who's signing their [__] checks I
mean that's what you got to do yes you
got to take them aside you don't brow
beat them
you just say listen I'm paying you to do
a job here all right and if you know if
you have a problem with that
then I'm gonna find somebody else all
right and then that's it and then you
let them look away
don't let them stare you down and then
that that's [__] it and let me tell
you something you can find another
plumber
and just know that if you're in business
every person you hire is not going to be
the last person you hire some people are
going to work some people aren't it's
like [__] dating that's just it's
just how it is all right so you don't
take any [__] out there
all right and if they really start
talking [__] to you then you got to go
Jerky Boys
with a [__] ratchet
plumbers you don't take [__] from the
customers
that's right all you do is Plumb [__]
that's what you do you get the [__] out
of the [__] toilet but you don't take
any [__] from these people that's right
all right that's it that's the podcast
go [__] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday and then I had a great
time with you and it's great to have you
back on the podcast yes I missed it wow
all right